اذا جاز لنا السؤال ما الفرق في هذه
الحاله بين النظام الشمولي الحالي واين
نظام شمول قادم فيه ايران
المحليه كما صرت بان هذا النظام العسكريه
ربما سيء منحه بعض لحوريات فطبقه الوسطى
مثلا تنازلات فيما يخص الحجاب او
ربما حريات اخرى في المجتمع بشكل
يستطيع ان يحقق لحارسه بين الطبقه الوسطى
ولكنه لحرس الثوري ان يمنح الحريات
السياسيه الطبقه الوسطى ولهذا السبب فعلى
المدى البعيد فان الانقسام بين الدوله سوف
يستمر الطبقه الوسطى هو التي طالب الحقوق
السياسيه اليوم ستطالب بالحقوق السياسيه
ايضا عندما لحارس الثوري همم اداره البلاد
عندما تحدث عن السياسات الامن الخارجي
فانلات كبيره
سقط جمهوريه الاسلاميه كلها ستستمر واعتقد
بان ايران بقياده الحرس الثوري ستفعل كل
ما في ويسعها ل- اا
تقول لبث نفوذها حتى خارج الطاقه الخليج
والى الدول العربيه واعتقد بان ستوري
سيستمروا ببرنامجه النووي
ويرث طموحات النوويه وطموحات الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه واعتقد بان ايران ستستمر
ببرنامجها الصاروخي كما اعتقد بان ايران
ستستمر
بانخراطها في النزاعات الاقليميه عبر
الوكاله وهذا الشيء فعله نظام الشعب
وفعلته وجمهور اسلاميه تحت قياده الدينيه
وتوقعوا هل من الحرس الثوري ان يستمر بفعل
نفس هذه الاشياء